hello everyone and welcome back to our
daily one rapid game unleashes I just um
uh started preparing lunch and it will
take some 20 minutes for it to cook uh
and I have time to play one rapid game
so let's do it we are uh continuing
where we left off so we had the white
pieces in the previous game probably we
are getting the black pieces in this one
but you can never be sure uh yeah we get
the black pieces and our opponent is uh
Z 34 so uh we'll see what happens like I
said if it's an E4 I will go for the for
the Sicilian probably the hyper
accelerated Dragon you guys said that
you prefer uh if I play that instead of
my usual Scandinavian uh even though
Scandinavian is my opening of choice
when I you know try to play for real but
I I would very much like love to become
a sicilian player so we might as well
try that so he goes for the uh he
doesn't go for the standard stuff uh he
wants to go Knight to C3 probably F4
next so I don't know how to play this
but uh we'll
see uh no he he plays it with Knight to
C3 and D4 very very interesting does
this changes anything sort of maybe it
doesn't maybe it doesn't we'll see yeah
we'll go Knight F6 and still go Knight
here
um yeah okay so now he goes for this
okay so do we have to kick away the
queen right away
now
um how does this change anything now we
could yeah okay we could play that but
we could also we could also just play
Knight the C6 and the D6 right away to
stop any E5 ideas he might
have yeah very
interesting
huh okay
so go
D6 he can still play this yeah okay so
he will play
it I don't know how good that is
actually yeah do I do I do I want to
sort of give up a pawn
here yeah I don't mind I actually mind
oh so wow I actually did not want to
play that I actually just blundered a
piece here wow let me just uh try and
see if I can take that back
nah wow I have no idea why I did that I
I skipped a move in my head uh but okay
yeah it's not a
problem it's not a problem we will we
will try to make the best of
this all right so now this is a
completely different game now we're just
down
material and what do we have to show for
it absolutely nothing absolutely we we
do have one Pawn for that piece
so uh let's let's try to make the best
of it let's uh let's hope our opponent
uh also makes a silly
mistake uh probably he will not but you
never know I I've seen it
happened all right
so I I I did request for take back our
opponent declined the take back yeah I
skipped the move in my head I don't know
what happened
there but uh yeah I'm I'm pretty sure it
happens to everyone and it
will uh it it will happen to you at some
point uh sometimes I've seen people just
resign when that happens but it's still
I mean it's still a game that we can
learn from now he has this huge
obligation where he's just up uh up a
full piece uh or rather I have one Pawn
for the piece
and he has to prove it uh he can't he
can't just relax and play whatever
because he might make some sort of a
mistake all right so he goes after the
B7 pawn and we already blunder a piece
so we don't want to we don't want to
give uh him any unnecessary
material uh so
h
yeah let's go
B6 not the
best but what are you going to
do yeah I it be it'd be great if I was
at least a little bit better on
time yeah so also one thing to consider
is maybe try playing a little bit
faster but precise so we have to we have
to go for faster but
precise yeah probably something like
Bishop to H6 will come at some point so
the bishop does belong on G7 although I
don't mind if he plays it probably my
Rook will go to
E8 all right so we do want to go back
that's for
sure
um yeah he'll probably play C4 or
something all right so we are better
better now on
time uh oh C3 yeah he's playing this
very carefully as he should yeah no need
to rush
anything no need to rush anything so how
can we
take any advantage of the position we we
definitely don't want to trade yeah
trading would be very bad for us
yeah we have to keep as many pieces on
the board for as long as
possible let's go here and let's go here
all right so we are holding
on still he will have to prove that an
extra piece is enough to win the game
all right so he wants to trade Bishops
as he
should
and uh well F6 is not a move you should
play in in in a situation where you know
it's like move 12 of the Sicilian
Defense uh we are down a piece so we are
going to play it to create a sort of a
sort of a massive Center
here and uh yeah I would
probably love to reposition my Bishop
somewhere on this diagonal but the
Knight here is controlling this
Square all right so if he wants to give
up his light Square Bishop for my knight
I will allow it even though we're
trading and we don't want to
trade yeah but he might just yeah no he
can't yeah he might just even capture
here yeah might not be a terrible move
yeah because if he captures he also
guards the bishop so I don't have the in
between capture and if I capture and if
he captures I capture he captures with
check yeah I have to move the king and
then he picks up the free Knight no he's
going to go this way yeah I wonder if
Knight captures was maybe the move but
okay maybe then I have the in between
Knight captures on B2 yeah maybe it's uh
okay so not a lot but we do have the
advantage of the bishop
pair uh yeah so he he does it this
way
uh very nice very nice very nice all
right so let's go let's go
here
yeah probably just Knight here
now yeah definitely not getting getting
a lot for this yeah of course that's
what what everyone would
play oh this was this was
bad all
right now we're not now we don't even
have a pawn for the piece but we're
still waiting for for that one mistake
we need only
one now let's go
here yeah I I did blunder there but when
when your when your position is so bad
when uh you know everything's already
gone wrong it's it's very hard to make
uh precise moves because there are so
many problems in the position yeah we're
not going to trade we're not going to
trade no
way maybe maybe C7 was a little bit
better to get the Rook into the game but
I don't know if I will be using the dile
to get my Rooks into the game he can
just move the queen and uh offer trades
here on the defile so it's not the best
Let's uh let's just Advance some
pawns yeah maybe this one would be
better first yeah top knight E5 and then
we go sorry Knight D4 and then we
continue
yeah it's not a lot but you know we're
we're
working we're working with something
here all right all right let's go all
the
way all the way here can probably play
G3 that's true but then I'll just play
put the Rook here and already uh I'm
very happy if he moves any of the Pawns
in front of his King his position is
always better that's uh I mean
that's
that's but that's just the way it is but
um yeah maybe he can play like maybe
this oh he found the queen trade nice
okay that's super
sad he found the queen
trade all
right so now he's up a full
Knight it's not the not the best
position to be
in okay so that's definitely how to do
it uh trapping my
Rook how do we get out of
this yeah okay all
right now we're down material and our
Rook is out of the game this is becoming
one one sad game but still it's not
impossible for him to make a
mistake okay so what does what does he
want
here now it's sort of a he maybe gave us
he maybe gave us one opportunity to
advance the
pawn yeah and we're going to take
it we're going to take it sort of as a
way maybe to get our Rook back into the
game it's not a lot and it's not easy to
still get the Rook into the game even
though okay so he played this
H yeah that's nice that's very
nice okay so he's probably going to take
with the Rook
here he'll probably take with the
Rook
and then yeah now he'll take with the
pawn that's very original very original
indeed all right so now at least we have
a passed Pawn let's go Rook
F6 uh we are putting the rook in front
of the bishop but we if the Knight moves
we do have an in between check and if it
does if he doesn't move we can double up
on the H file which is an ugly file to
double up on but uh um I'm I mean I'm
working with what I have
here yeah just trying to trying to make
uh make it as resilient as possible for
him for me but for him not to not to win
easily and maybe if he gets low on time
if he gets low on time enough that is I
we'll be able to maybe pull pull a
rabbit out of a hat even though I doubt
it yeah so he goes here he wants uh he
wants me to he wants me actually to
double up here and then he will just put
a rook here and that's pretty much it
pretty much it for
me
um but yeah let's do it let's do
it yeah that and now we should also
unpin because Rook to G1 is
coming yeah we should also definitely
unpin
here then maybe maybe just maybe we have
some Rook H3 followed by E3 doesn't
really do anything but it gives me a
move at at this point I'm uh not really
looking for Waste uh okay so this Rook
will come forward Ward okay so this
would be pretty bad because this check
would would win the bishop and I don't
want to do
that so and also he might just play Rook
captur uh Bishop here so it's uh ugly
however you put it I might just put my
Bishop
here yeah know that that's also also
quite
losing um
yeah but if it takes I do have the in
between
captures very unclear yeah that that
actually might be my best
bet no he he could just give a check I
could move and then he just takes
it yeah nothing nothing really works
here h
yeah I've got nothing better I've got
nothing
better and even this is pretty bad even
this is pretty bad so now now I'm kind
of forced to play
this
yeah at least I will connect my pawns
and have a pass Pawn for his Bishop so
that's that's the most I can get out of
the position just uh being annoying
and he's still not better on
time yeah he will probably win this make
no mistake I mean it's an extra piece
but still it's uh it's what you know
when I was covering the alpha Zero
versus stockfish games you know there
was a
completely uh winning POS okay so now he
wants to deliver a check it's not a lot
but yeah you can definitely do it let's
just go after the the this here maybe it
will yeah he also wants to just play
this Rook on the seventh is very
strong so yeah with two yeah what I was
talking about yeah when we were covering
those Alpha Zero versus stockfish games
um uh Alpha zero was like winning
completely winning but stockfish still
made it annoyingly difficult for Alpha
zero to win for like 100 moves and if
you could do that as a human at your
level and of course at your opponent's
level uh you will give him many many
chances to make a
mistake uh but you have to play really
really strong moves and really tricky
moves uh in order to do that so we are
again better on time he's now you know
he's looking for for
ways that I mean it's there's not really
all that much to think about yeah okay
so he will double up here I will offer a
trade yeah he will probably just capture
here I mean this is what I wanted sort
of for the bishop to be stuck here
guarding the pawn and the the pass Pawn
is not
spectacular by any means but it's still
a pass Pawn you know if you give me two
moves yeah of course of course you will
do
that of course the King goes into the
game
[Music]
yeah
yeah that's great if I could have gotten
my Rook into the game somehow yeah let's
just Advance the pawn there's there's
nothing to there's nothing to hope for
here he's making my Rook useless maybe
maybe this was the way to go sort of
forcing him to move the Rook but I don't
get anything by him moving The Rook
because I can't cover the D6 Square okay
so let's force him back go defend your
rook and now we
repeat or do we have this check is the
check
anything no it's
not is it wow did he did we did we
actually achieve this position and win
and win
it wow I actually don't believe that we
were able to do
this yeah it's the it's the one
possibility that kept us going and uh we
managed to do
it
that's the good stuff yeah Never Never
Surrender Never
Surrender yeah okay
so yeah uh that's what I was talking
about uh a piece up is a lot but if you
play you know precise moves and we
didn't have a lot to go on we had that
one pass pawn and we had the hope of of
it doing something maybe at some point
in the game uh it was actually enough
for us to win this but yeah let's uh uh
let's analyze the game regardless even
though I mean it's it's a game where we
blundered but uh yeah maybe maybe maybe
there was something really hidden in the
position that we could have used but
yeah this is uh yeah with this Knight
here yeah maybe something else okay so
so this is sort of greeted with with
this or this yeah okay anything is
possible this is still pretty much just
an opening Choice yeah okay perfectly
fine yeah okay okay so I have I I have
to capture first and then play Bishop G7
that's the move I already played in my
head uh but yeah uh okay
so so this is all perfectly fine yeah
perfectly fine it's nothing I mean we're
just down a
piece which is of course uh terrible
yeah I played the yeah here when I
played this knight move okay so
capturing is better first yeah okay so
we even blunder the pawn there yeah we
played pretty much the only moves that
we
could all right so this is fine I mean
when I say fine yeah he was even able to
trade Queens
off okay so captures
captus I'm just checking if there was
some sort of a clean way for him to
finish things off yeah uh first get
playing The Rook here and then doubling
up uh sort of a
yeah I mean it it's hard to evaluate
because everything is winning for him
like literally every move he plays is
winning for him but he did give me this
one chance um I mean unbelievable but
that's that's the you know it was a a
tiny
tiny uh piece of hope that was probably
never going to work but unless he does
something like this King G2 was an
excellent move he got his King into the
game but then he should have just you
know continued playing something
uh but yeah here he he gave gave back
the advantage and now even though okay
uh we were both down maybe to around a
minute I think he was below a minute I
was like a minute and a half uh now it's
of course pointless because I would just
collect pawns and it's way too easy to
play this Rook versus Bishop uh so yeah
uh you know what can I say never
resigned and good things might happen
that not most of the times but sometimes
they will uh so hope you enjoy that and
yeah we we won a game that we really
shouldn't have won W but then again uh
we will also lose games that we we
really shouldn't lose so you know it's
even Steven on some days uh so yeah once
again really hope you enjoyed it uh
thank you all for watching uh and I will
see you soon also check out two of my
previous videos here until next
time